let's go to norway let's go to norway
speaking of smart and pale let's go to
norway let's go to norway so in norway
norway will ferrell comes out we can't
show it
but if you saw it you know we can't show
the norway the the gm commercial
and he punches the uh what do you call
it
can we actually show the commercial or
no mario i don't know if we can show the
commercial or not
if we can i don't want to show it no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no a homeless
looking will ferrell by the way so he
punches scraggly looking
ticked off because norway is now the
leading country in the world for
electrical vehicles so go ahead i'll
turn it over to you here what happens
next
moment so this commercial actually came
on early in the super bowl too it was
first quarter so it was early it was i
don't know if it was first or second but
it was
it was early so the commercial came on
and then uh yesterday
my uncle actually sent me a video where
there's a norwegian university that
responded to the commercial it's like a
dig at the commercial
and will ferrell specifically and i want
us to watch that mario if you want to
get it prepared
mario's sitting over there in the corner
just enjoying the show
yep full screen damn it
holy mackerel olaf olaf this just
alright for you
uh it smells like uh fishy i don't care
the americans are coming and will
ferrell does not look happy
what do we do we have to make a public
apology and we have to get rid of
anything else that might make will
envious in any way
if you get so annoyed about our electric
vehicles i can't imagine how we'll react
to all the other stuff
all right action dear mr farrell
dear general motors on behalf of our
university
and the rest of norway we are truly
sorry we want to maintain
a strong and sound relationship with the
united states and of course
we shouldn't have become the leading
country in the world when it comes to
electrical vehicles
without checking with you first and we
fully understand that you want to punch
us in the face
but our collaboration with you is of
utmost importance
our student exchange for instance and
pay tuition
again i pay tuition one more time i pay
tuition
good but i don't pay tuition education
in norway is free
even for us americans well i know that
but will ferrell does not have to know
we also hope that we can continue our
extensive research collaboration with
many american universities
we collaborate for instance she's
actually the president
yeah good afternoon director i was
hoping i could talk to you about our
battery research
uh you know that project that uses clean
renewable hydropower to recycle and
reuse batteries from electric vehicles
okay but we'll have to talk about this
later this is really not a good time
okay what we're trying to say is that if
you want
the opening of the battery factory then
yes yes yes
what we're trying to say is that if you
want to become the number one country in
the world when it comes to electrical
vehicles
we won't stand in your way we'll even
help you and co-create the knowledge you
need
excuse me hello hi rector
i just wanted to say goodbye and i'll
see you next year
i'm off for my one year paid maternity
leave
[Music]
sorry about that not sorry wow
i'm on maternity leave and she goes
skiing
[Music]
sorry wow
straight up good for them and and the
crazy thing is this is a 2 000
subscriber channel in a day it has 200
000 views
i mean people gonna but the point is
norway got a big shot and everybody's
curious you know what norway's really
doing
yeah no okay so norway clapback yes who
is that lady exactly
she is the president or like a duke of
the university kind of
okay i'm a university for a second i
thought i was like the president of
norway
but let's not talk let's not forget the
underlying themes there that they're
i mean they're very political they are
taking shots at america
they are taking shots at capitalism they
are taking shots at our entire
economic system so norway is norway
capitalism socialism that message just
sponsored a
socialism so so norway has a socialistic
state
but it has a capitalistic market so you
have the free market but then the state
kind of
comes in and takes over so you have for
a maternal relief like a nicer version
of china
um a highly functioning democratic
politics
sure um and the thing is but uh
obviously norway has the money in the
oil money seven trillion dollars to
support it yeah
and they have can you unpack that what
that means what you just said uh so
norway norway's a smaller country
you have five and a half million people
i think yep uh you have
a population that where most people are
obviously working you're kind of just
and um working and taking care of it
you're paying in and then you're getting
back from the state um norway
also is a big oil company norway could
technically be
like a saudi arabia or a country yeah
this is what's crazy the fact that they
have that however
they early on as soon as they started
they said basically we're going to put
this on a fund and
for future generations so they haven't
tapped into it this year i think was
like the first year because of kovit
they actually tapped into it
in since the existence of the fund so
here you have a company that or a
country that's saving up
and storing the money for later purposes
but then they're also taxing people a
lot
or and making sure that you're paying
for the the goods of the state
what is what is the taxes over the high
level uh i think so i think
it's 30 40 percent is typical is a
pretty typical
tax i think i paid 25 or 28
when i was making 30 40 grand
or so so you you paid you paid less than
30 percent when you're making 30 40
questions
and their top line what's the top line
does it go about 50 or not that i'm not
sure
okay i'd be curious to know because tax
rate in norway if you want to look at
that yeah the highest tax rate in norway
is tax rate
but is there marginal tax brackets is it
how does that work in norway
uh i think it's marginal yeah um i'm not
too familiar with it because i haven't i
didn't work there too much
okay but i think right he was uh 17
he left norway 38 24 but wait a minute
sweden's top president i see 57
but that's sweden that's sweden well
what's the difference
[Laughter]
38.4 is the high does that sound about
right or is there higher than 38.4
i think that sounds about right okay i
mean 38.4 to be high to be honest with
you
you know what this says to you there's
got to be something higher now let me
tell you what this
what does this say to you okay what does
it say to you well it says that our
taxes are damn too high
which means what which means we're
overpaying yeah and it's irresponsible
people that have no clue what to do with
our money because we have california
that pays
60 percent crazy six this number
campaign is right this number
there's there's there's one tax that's
not included here which is the value
added to
the research over here uh norway has a
value added tax so everything you buy
has a twenty five value added tax which
obviously when you're
paying and you're buying uh makes it
quite expensive
and kai said so what is that uh it
shouldn't be
thrown under the rug but uh norway saves
you know the americans uh we don't save
money because we're always
saving that money is what you're saying
that money you know that's something i
can get behind
but guys on on a i'm actually being very
very if that is the real number
okay could you get behind 38
top line okay i'm not buying that though
we got to check our stats here i'm
thinking the top line has to be at least
50 percent
in a in a socialist country or whatever
however you want to
they're probably they're probably no
that's that's right that's what it says
i'm telling
i'm on a different yeah so it says uh uh
denmark is 45.
sweden is also close to 45. you know
then it says taxes okay that's if it's
if that's the real number u.s moving to
sweden yeah
moving to norway not about it's not even
that u.s is
still the greatest country in the world
but the folks who are get it's like
think about it this way you have a money
manager
okay and say let's just say you have a
million bucks with a money manager you
give it to bobby
who's your money manager at morgan
stanley dean witter
you stay with him for a year two years
three years four years five years
okay five years later your million is
980.
your brother had a million dollars
at the same time you put with bobby he
put with mary
at merrell lynch hypothetically bank of
america right
his million dollars five years later is
1.9 million what are you questioning
you're at 980 000 he's at 1.9 million
honestly what are you thinking about
what's the first question you would say
paul if that happened to you you and
your brother have a million bucks at the
same time you give your money to morgan
stanley
with bobby five years later your million
is 980.
he manages it you give him the
discretionary yeah and your brother and
merrill
be available your millions 1.9 million
what are you asking what are your
questions i get a lot of questions ask
the question
hey where am i invested so what do you
what are your fees what are you calling
this guy
you're on the phone with bobby what are
you asking bobby i'll say the market's
up 10
for the last x amount of years yeah how
am i down a what about where
what's my allocation strategy am i in
stocks my bonds where am i out of here
hey adam you got to
trust me because the strategy i'm taking
right now is this and here's what's
going on even though right now i feel
like the next
the money going yeah the money's going
right now to small cap and small caps
taking a hit and we invested heavily
into oil
and the last three years haven't been
the best for oil and real estate so
what do you ask let's talk fees for a
second i mean what's your aom are you
one percent i mean i assume i know that
up front right i mean that's yeah so our
aom is a little bit uh as morgan stanley
dean would've rather than paying one
percent it's about 1.5 percent here with
us
because you are with morgan stanley dean
when with the top oh the luxury of so
what do you say next
that's that's how i look at this so the
point i'm trying to make to you guys is
we all essentially a part of your money
manager that we all have is the us
government
u.s government is your individual
everybody listening to this that's in
america it is everybody's money manager
the u.s government got it every time you
make a hundred thousand dollars and you
pay your
thirty thousand dollars in taxes thirty
five thousand dollars in taxes whatever
that number is that's 35 000
over 10 years is what 350 000 yeah
what's the right question to ask what
did you do
money going with my 350 right you have
350 and i'm not even a millionaire i'm
only making a hundred thousand dollars
i'm paying let's just say that person is
right i'm only making a hundred thousand
dollars thirty five percent
over ten years i paid you three hundred
fifty thousand dollars show it to me
where's it at
show it to me i wanna infrastructure
health care where is the social security
medicare what do you need the 44 percent
that we have right now
top line 46 is the highest u.s that's
not in norway
in norway okay but here it's 40
39. say 40 percent okay
state you're looking at well california
right
now huh california is what 13. dude if
you look at california's number you're
looking at sixty percent nearly fifty
five to sixty percent you're making over
what four hundred thousand markets
you're saying
thousand is not a lot of money if you
put 400 000 if you put 100 000
and i'm paying whatever i'm paying for
where is it what are we doing with it
okay so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye